- If your job is reach
out to and engage people
who are in trouble, that's your job,
that part of our community
does not trust the police.
I'm a street worker, I'm engaging
people who are in trouble.
I can say, "You know,
the police have a program
"that they have that
can get you in the union
"and get you a job, so
if you want to give up
"this lifestyle, and get some training,
"so that you could have some skills,
"to be able to get a job,
and get placed in a job,
"I can help you do that.
"It's a program that comes
out of the police department."
That's how you begin to
break down those barriers.
And now that young person
goes from being unemployed,
and involved in negative
activity in the community,
to working.
And the street worker, the
community, and the police,
were all a part of making that happen.